the health of the people is really the
foundation upon which all their
happiness and all their powers as a
state depend did you ever stop to
realize how much all these health
activities mean in your life let's take
a look at the Browns a typical family
whose life and whose problems are not so
very different from your own from the
very beginning of Frank and Helen Browns
wedded life their health department has
been helping them achieve the blessings
of health and making there's a more
healthful community before they could
obtain a marriage license in the state
where they lived they had to show that
they were free from venereal infection
an important factor in their future
happiness and in the health of any
children who might be born unto them the
doctor draws a sample of blood for a
test this should be made a routine part
of every physical examination and must
bring to light many unsuspected cases of
syphilis in the Health Department
laboratory the blood sample submitted by
the doctor are tested at the completion
of this test Frank brown sample will
show up negative no syphilis but the man
who followed him into the doctor's
office has a positive test this means he
has syphilis and requires prompt
treatment early continuous treatment
will cure syphilis and prevent its
further spread
why does the Health Department come in
on this it wants to find the contacts of
the infected man and see that they
undergo treatment if it is necessary
since continuity of treatment is so
essential for cure the health
authorities are also vitally interested
in seeing that those under treatment
keep it up until a cure is effected when
their first baby was expected mrs. Brown
underwent a blood test as part of her
prenatal examination why because
treatment of expectant mothers who have
syphilis will prevent their babies being
born with this disease together with
other expectant mothers mrs. Brown had
the benefit of valuable instruction
given by a competent health nurse
at home to mrs. Brown found the public
health nurse most helpful this work was
carried on in complete cooperation with
their private physician their first baby
was born at home and the physician
called to engage a maternity nurse to
assist at delivery a service offered by
many health departments the nurse helps
to prepare for any emergency warming
beds or baby incubators must be
available in case the newborn babe is
premature ready at a moment's notice the
maternity nurse answers the call happy
in the knowledge that she has guided the
expectant mother in healthful living and
has helped her prepare for a safe
delivery and a happy convalescence
doing fine thanks each year thousands of
mothers and babies benefit by this
maternity service does health work pay
what do you think getting the facts
needed for baby's birth registration
these people are going to a lot of
trouble to obtain birth certificates
which they must have for employment or
for many other reasons the proper
registration of births is of importance
to prevent future difficulties along
with other records these birth records
comprise the vital statistics which
serve as a guide to health workers
showing them where they need to put the
most effort and how successful their
work has been
the health department's worked was not
completed when the baby was born it
carries through after the birth of the
baby our suspicions aroused by a
persistent hacking cough the nurse make
some inquiries which lead her to believe
an examination for tuberculosis is in
order
the doctors thorough examination which
includes the x-ray reveals an active
case of tuberculosis
thus possible infection of the browns
baby was prevented and the woman
received the treatment she needed all
because of the thoroughness of observing
and following through which are a part
of Health Department training and
practice all the home context of the
tubercular woman are checked carefully
when the baby is 6 months old the nurse
reminds mrs. Brown of the necessity of
smallpox vaccination and immunisation
against diphtheria surely this safe
process is more sensible than running
the risk of catching these dangerous
diseases the Browns next-door neighbors
were guilty of a terrible act of
carelessness they fail to immunize their
child against diphtheria one day it's
struck
as soon as the doctor makes a diagnosis
of diphtheria he gives panto toxin
sometimes it is necessary to take
cultures on other members of the family
to control the spread of the disease
when a case of communicable disease is
reported the Health Department comes
into play once more it offers laboratory
service to confirm the doctor's
diagnosis it safeguards the community by
isolating the sick individual once again
the public health nurse is of invaluable
help here she is instructing the child's
mother on the proper technique to use in
the sickroom this is important in
controlling the spread of the disease
the school of course is an important
place to work for prevention of spread
in many communicable diseases this work
is aided by the use of sanitary drinking
fountain such as these and by rigid
inspection of the entire sanitary system
the school has more than a preventive
role to play it is also an ideal place
for teaching the positive lessons of
health not only by classroom instruction
but by every tried means at its command
does the Health Education Department and
ever to guide the people in the paths of
healthful living it is not sufficient
for science to learn new facts about
nutrition these facts must be brought
home to us so that we will learn how to
make use of them in our daily lives
since many health faults need correction
before a child as of school age
preschool examinations dental as well as
medical are of great importance the
school is a good place to develop a
physical education program which will
build strong bodies for our children
but to return to our friends the Browns
the milk they drink so essential in the
healthful diet must be safe milk
carefully guarded from contamination in
every step of its handling from the
producer to the consumer healthy cows
tested to show they are free from
tuberculosis mastitis and contagious
abortion scrupulous cleanliness of the
dairy barn the cows in the milkers hens
rinsing of others with bactericidal
solution
the inspector makes a thorough check of
the milk house also adequate
hand-washing facilities stove to heat
water for washing and sterilizing cans
and buckets check clean milk aprons
check cabinet for storing strainer pads
chemical disinfectants and other loose
equipment water for cooling milk down to
a safe temperature clean buckets and
cans check milk produced under these
conditions is clean milk but as a
further safeguard it must be pasteurized
when the milk reaches the pasteurization
plant it is dumped in properly covered
receiving baths and sample for tests
checking the effectiveness of the
sanitary methods employed in production
from the receiving tank the milk is
transferred through Cemetery piping to
the pasteurizer which is equipped with
leak-proof Inlet and outlet valves each
pasteurizer has indicating recording and
airspace thermometers after each day's
operation all equipment which comes in
contact with the milk must be
disassembled washed and placed upon
racks where it remains for inspection
immediately after being used it is
assembled and sterilized don't tanks
filters pasteurizer sanitary pipes
coolers bottlers and individual bottles
must be kept scrupulously clean samples
of the producers milk is analyzed
microscopically by using the breed
microscopic technique
the effectiveness of cooling the
cleanliness of utensils and the presence
of mastitis can be determined by this
test
after being pasteurized a bacterial
flick count is made of the finished
product at this time a phosphatase test
is made to determine the efficiency of
pasteurization
the result of the foregoing precaution
in producing handling and processing
milk is great a pasteurized milk when
the Browns eat in a restaurant their
health is safeguarded by sanitary
inspection here is a sanitary inspector
checking on dish washing equipment pure
water is always an important health
problem but the Browns don't have to
worry about that because their water
comes from the municipal plant which is
subject to constant inspection
but the people who live out in the
country must obtain their water from
their own Wells properly constructed and
located they are safe but many a case of
typhoid has been traced back to a
polluted well cause bike rack platform
split base and no stuffing box the spout
is flame to destroy bacteria and the
sample is collected in a sterilized
bottle which may be obtained from an
approved laboratory tested in the health
department's water laboratory
the water proves to be highly polluted
with colon bacteria an indication of
possible typhoid contamination advice on
well construction and location is
available to you for the asking simply
write your health department another
function of the health department is the
inspection of swimming pools the Browns
have a further advantage over their
rural neighbors in the disposal of human
waste that problem is taken care of for
them by a municipal sewage disposal
plant which renders these wastes non
injurious to health
we're water under pressure is not
available it is impractical to build a
septic tank the best solution is a
sanitary toilet built according to
Health Department specification in order
to come about those diseases which are
waterborne the sanitary engineer also
works toward the prevention of stream
pollution in still another way is his
health department interested in Frank
Brown's health aroused by a case of
silicosis which occurred in a fellow
worker of his the director of industrial
hygiene sends his inspector to the plant
for Frank works to collect dust samples
and the industrial hygiene laboratory
proves the existence of health hazards
which must be eliminated
a still further service of the health
department is the distribution of
certain drugs vaccine and serum to
doctors for use on those who cannot
afford to pay for them thus no one need
be denied the benefits of modern
medicine fortunate indeed all the Browns
to have this intensive health protection
once available only to city dwellers for
the families that dwell in the great
rural areas or along the shaded Main
streets of our small towns adequate full
time health work has not existed for so
very long in many areas it does not
exist yet even though this is an age of
speed distances in the country are too
great for health activity to be carried
out with a maximum effectiveness from a
central location such as the State
Health Department to accomplish the most
good health activity must be localized
it must serve the people of one County
or a few counties combined to make a
district thus does it establish the
intimacy and thoroughness which ensure
maximum effectiveness the staff of the
local health department its director
it's public health nurses it's sanitary
officers and it's clerical force are all
in health work on a full-time basis they
have been carefully to work in the best
universities and through lectures they
keep up with the newest developments in
their field naturally thus equipped and
lust devoted they will do a good job of
protecting the health of the people they
serve those organize local health work
pay these figures show how deaths from
certain diseases have been reduced as a
result of instituting full-time health
work behind these coal statistics is the
story of reduction of needless suffering
and preventable death
you there are you protected like the
Browns by organized local health service
if so cooperate with it in every way you
can if not who then is responsible for
your community's health are you getting
the health protection you ought to have